how do you write a great scene hmm how
do I write a great scene well usually I
jump in in the middle of the scene so
it's sort of like the scene doesn't
necessarily begin from an organic place
maybe when I entered the scene that
they're already there right and then
whatever it is that's happening I just
let it organically play out and then I
go back and sort of tweak it for
language and authentic conflict if that
makes any sense to you what are you
gonna say you sounds like you go right
in the heart of it and then you bookend
it later with the yeah else yeah because
if I try and make it perfect I have to
like black that's what it is
this is what it's about laughs that's
what's happening and then I go and
finesse it otherwise it'll I'll be
trying to make it right and that's you
know you just I just need to try and
make it make it real not right it
doesn't have to be right just needs to
be real that makes any sense
it does it sounds like you don't like
anything forced you like it just to just
be spontaneous yeah spontaneous is good
because that gives your characters room
to surprise you
I mean having an idea what the scene is
about what's the conflict what do they
want what how is it serving the story
those things are sort of around in my
head and I just sort of let the
characters have at it and then tweak it
a little bit later I mean obviously you
know you want to tweak it before it's
it's supposed to be funny you want to
make sure that there's some humor in
there and all that kind of stuff but if
you just kind of put it all out there
whatever or the kernel of truth or
organic you know thing that's happening
in the in the scene will sort of happen
and then you can sort of mold around
that and cut stuff that you know we
shouldn't be there even if it is funny
or even if it is if it's not moving the
thing for it you know what's the
favorite scene of a film that you
we're not a part of that you wish you'd
written so real so great oh lord have
mercy oh my god
favorite scene there's so many Wow
maybe when you were back in college do
you remember one that was just like
since I know you you like stuff from the
80s like I do 90s and it seems like that
it's just a more richer time yeah I mean
there's stuff that immediately comes to
mind like I'm sort of a romantic so of
course I'm gonna go to like When Harry
Met Sally that kind of stuff because I'm
a romantic that's why I can't believe
that's what comes to my brain right now
okay
well the pie scene is a good one
oh god what's the other one about last
night stuff like that I mean cuz I'm
just such a no I'm this yeah I am a
sucky romantic no that's one but of
course there's brilliant scenes that I'm
not coming to me right now at all one of
the well okay you're here if we want to
be really you know filmmaker II my
favorite filmmaker is Christoph
Kozlowski he did a three colors red blue
and white and just brilliant right brony
filmmaker and my first short film was
based this is actually my first short
film was inspired by blue which the
opening scene is so haunting and
incredible if you've never seen the
youth I mean really it's Juliette
Binoche she's in a car with her husband
and child and it's like this haunting
visual way that they show what happens
and there's an accident and ultimately
what happens is her whole family dies
except for her so she spends the whole
movie grieving but really trying to
eliminate any
of that life because she kids too
painful for her and so that inspired me
it's it's my first short film is
basically is literally inspired by that
it's about a man whose wife dies and he
based he's haunted by the memories it's
the opposite though he's haunted by the
memory so he wants to you know kill
himself
because he can't deal with all the pain
of the love and all that stuff it
actually has a happy ending oh it's the
ending Christophe Kozlowski's like
whatever
you